では あの質問とかございましたら
一つ前のスライドもう一回見せて
죄ください どうも お疲れ様です
えーと 今日のテーマとはちょっと若干
今日のテーマとはちょっと違う質問なんですけれども
先日 法典解説の部分ですね
誤解について教えていただいたんですけれども
その誤解をですね なくすための具体的な解決
解決方法というのがありましたら教えていただきたいです
その時言ったでしょうに
説法の時は 説法の時は言いましたよ
理解できてなかった 理解できていなかったのかも
もう一度  別に言って 誤解は自分の感情でしょうに
欲をなくすだけ それから別に方法ってないんですよ
欲張らないことでしょうに
怒らないことでしょうに
あんまり大げさに考えるとなくならないんですよ
じゃあ欲張らないことにしましたでいいんです
じゃあ怒らないことにしました
でいいんです 誤解ってそういうものでしょ
それから昏睡睡眠でしょ
じゃあもう昏睡睡眠に陥らないことにしました
眠気が出たら頑張ってやるぞと
冷たい水でもかぶってもう踏ん張るぞと
それだけ そういうシンプルでなくなります
うん はい 他ご質問があったらよろしいし
なかったらありがたいし
はい  あの その無知のループを断つということもかなり力がいると思うんですけど
その力を出すために必要な
その最低限のエネルギーみたいなのがないとループから脱出できないと思うんですけども
うん その辺はどのようにその引き出してきて
何年質問したっても同じ質問ですね
分析的に見ると だからできないという結論で引いてるんですよ
はい まあそれは置いておいて
まあまあ すごい力が必要ですよ
無知のループだけじゃなくて
無知のループっていうのは最後に結果として出てくるとんでもないループだからね
それより先に貪瞋痴 怒り
あれこれとかね もうそういうループを切らなくちゃいけない
落ち込みとかね ループ切る方法っていうのは実況中継ですからね
だから私 最近言うのは頭の中で竜巻を起こしてください
実況中継のちゃんと頭の中で竜巻を起こしちゃえば
もう 1 日で治りますよ
皆様 何年も頑張るのを私にはどうすることもできませんだからやり方は言っているはずなんです
それから力が必要なんですね
だから座ったらストップモーションになりなさいと
30 分体じっと動かさないでいるということは
相当精進でしょうに この努力でものすごい精神的な力なんですよ
歩く時は胴体を全く動かさないで
上半身をね 足だけ動かして
しっかり 1時間も歩いて
それでかなり精神的な力がついてるはずなんです
ですから まあそんなところですよ
力はまあ言っている通りに力は必要ですよ
ちょこっと生ぬるく もう実況中継したんだからって生ぬるくやると
この 100 分の 1 秒の 100 分の 1 2 でもうループが回転するんだから
だから実況中継が竜巻でない限りはね
いわゆる考える余裕がなくなったというぐらいエネルギーで実況しなくちゃいけないんです
だから脳がフル回転させなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで この妄想が入らないようにするぞと言っちゃうと
これ脳にはもう耐え切れないほど仕事なんですよ
それで脳細胞は今 言葉
言語だけのセクションでやるのじゃなくて
これ言葉使ってるわけじゃないんだから
ただ何かラベリングするだけのことだから
これには至るところの神経細胞を使います
あちらこちらどちらでもいいんだから使うんです
仕事はもう火事状態だからね
もうとにかく取り出す
それで信仰回路いっぱいできますよ
脳の中で それできちゃうと
この過去生みたいとか何とかとかする場合の基本的な器ができてますよ
過去生を再現してみたっても
脳に移らないとね できませんだからね
どうせ心の問題ですから
脳は関係ないんだけど
まあ我々知識にする場合は脳が必要でしょうし
脳がバラバラで回路ができてなくて
例えば科学だけやったとか
音楽だけやったりすると
ほんの一部しかできてないでしょ
それで他の細胞とは関係なくなっちゃうしね
それではできませんだから
やっぱりこの実況中継って
これで全体的にニューロンを全部使ってるような
それは実験してないんだ
解剖してないんだから
私が言うことは単なる感想ですけど
いろいろ神経回路出来上がりますよと
誰もそれを試したことはないんですから
科学的な事実とはとは違いますけど
感想ですけど やっぱり普通の能力ではできないことだけ私は経験では知ってます
実況中継するためには
並大抵の力ではできません
だから竜巻を起こしちゃえば問題は解決します
はい はい  瞑想の話なんですけれども
瞑想をして竜巻を起こしているということは
主観的ではなく主観になっている
ん？ 主観的とかではなくて
主観そのものになっているということで
に対して  主観ではなく
主観そのものに 客体に対しての主観そのものになっていく方向性が
まあ主観といっても主観じゃないでしょう
実況中継は 手を挙げる場合は挙げる挙げるということでしょ
歩く場合 左足上げる 運ぶ
下ろすと実況するだけで主観にはなりません
実況しているものは確かに客観的に見ていると思う
それだったら瞑想じゃないんです
それはループでやっていることだからね
だから竜巻がなければダメなんです
私は足を上げるという風に実況は瞑想になりません
上げる 運ぶ 下ろす 英語だったらこのコンティニュアス進行形でやっていますよ
レーシング ムービング
プレッシングとかね その場合は私も他人も何ともないんですよ
例えば立っている場合は立ってますと日本語で言うでしょうね
英語だったらスタンディングだけ
スタンディング フィーリング
自分もいないし 他人もいないし
単なる進行形で動詞だけで
だから座る瞑想をする時は
私は特別にウェイティングウェイティングと待ちますというところを入れて
そこからでもいいんだから
客観的に第一人称なくして瞑想しなさいと
英語で指導する場合はすごい時間短くなるので
それほど問題になりません
これはちょっと使うラベルの問題でね
例えば日本語にもすることは不可能じゃないんですよ
足を上げますではなくて
上がりとかね 運びとかね
なんとなくね 文化的にはなんかちょっと
言いにくいということがありますから
だからそこもまあ脳使ってますからね
あまりにも変な単語を使っちゃうと
スムーズにこの立ちましか立ち足す負けが起こりません
だからそういうところも考えなくちゃいけないんです
でも 膨らみ縮みはもうちゃんと言いやすい
ありがたいことに 痛み
かゆみとか言いやすいんです
客観的に 歩く時はちょこっと無理ですからね
まあそういう微妙なハンディではないんで
微妙な差ですよ 文化的に
それはあんまり大げさにはない
ブッダの教えの世界ではね
それは解決する とにかく実況中継は主観的には決してなりません
あの観察者が観察するならば
それは瞑想ではありません
座る瞑想の場合は 私はよく言うのは
もう私がいないという想定でやってくださいと
そのために待ちます 待ちます
待ちます と言いながら
もうこれから私がいません
ということで 何があるのかと実況する
別に実況したっても 自分が実況するっていうことをいうふうに
人間の世界で思うかもしれませんだけど
心理学の場合は我々何やってるのかというと
単なるあのループを切断しているだけなんです
ループを切断するとどんどん力が出てくるし
知識が開発するし それでありのままの心理を見えてしまいます
あの 4つの心理を それで悟りに達するんです
道はしっかりしています
はい では  あの 思ったことがあるんですけど
あの生き物っていうのは
結局あの苦を追いかけて欲しがって
苦 苦がありますよね 苦を追いかけていて
捕まえて それで結局自分は苦しみたくないんだよって言ってるようなものなのかなって思ったんですけど
その考え方は  そういうことです
ありがとうございます
苦を追いかけて苦しみたくないというのですね
それはお釈迦様も同じことをおっしゃっています
もう一つだけなんですけれども
エコーの経の中で ヘッターワターちゃん平気ってあるじゃないですか
上から 2つ目のサッペブーターって
日本語訳で精霊って出てくるんですけど
なんだか私知らないんですけど
それって教えてください
ブータンに誰が入るか私もあまりわかりません
一応パーリ語でもあるし
そういう文化的な芸だからね
例えば神々以外のそういういろいろ目に見えない存在がいっぱいあるやと
タイの人々も自分なりの精霊思考があって
ミャンマーでも自分たちなりの精霊思考があって
スリランカではないんだけど
ヒンドゥー教文化だから
ヒンドゥー教から割り込んできた
まあそういう精霊的な思考がありましてね
まあそこは入れているでしょうね
そういう精霊がいるっていうのは見えたりするんでしょうか
ある人は知らない それはだから
いてもいなくてもどうでもいいんですから
いるならばはい どうぞと
功徳をあげますと だから生命を
なんていいますか 抜けません
仏教慈悲だからね だから他宗教の概念
文化の概念も全部使えます
例えば日本で回向するならば
もう八百万の神々に 神々に回向します
と言ったっても決して悪くないんです
なぜなら 日本文化では八百万の神々の思考はあるでしょうに
だから もしいるならば
はい どうぞと  少しわかりました
ありがとうございます
大塚さん 昨日の立松和平さんの話の中でですが
お母様の耳元で唱えている慈悲の瞑想
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
言葉を知りたいです  フルセットでしょう
まあわかります  一応わかります
もうその時言ったんだから
その立松さんが何やってるかわからないでしょ
改めて自分がその立場になった時に
慈悲の瞑想をする フルセットで言った方がいいのかと思う
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
ことで 一応生きとし生けるものの方ではいい可能性はあります
はっきり断言的には決まりませんだけど
例えば我々の場合はお互い様仏教だから
もうただの慈悲の瞑想でも普通にはいけますしね
まあ大体年取って弱くなってくると 1行に縮みますけどね
サッビーサッタ バンサクサッタという一畳に縮みますからね
時々サッビーサッタもカットしてスキタッタだけにする場合もあります
それでもその文化の人々は通じます
はい  昨日 私も立松和平さんの対談行ったんですけども
8時でお腹痛くなっちゃって
ちょっと帰ってきて質問し忘れたんですけれども
今の中にですね 食べてはいけないもので
ゾウとクマ それとヘビ
それとクマとトラですか
それだけは修行の中で食べてはいけないものっていうふうにされてるっていうあれがあったんですけれども
それは何か根拠がある
どちらかというとね まあやっぱり仏教はね
人が作って 昔はね 人が残ったものをあげるんだから
もうあまり贅沢ではなくて
何も言ってはいけないんですね
人は残ったものをくれると
それは食べて その人に祝福を念じる
あなたのおかげで修行できましたということで
だからあげる人々も このお坊さんたちの修行の功徳をね
もらいたくて でお布施をするんです
いくらでもこれだけはやめなさいという風になったんですよ
なぜかというと  このインド文化でも同じことですけど
動物はもうなんとか事故で何か死んじゃったら肉は捨てません
もったいないということで食べるんですね
それでトラの肉なんか持ってきちゃうと
これはお釈迦様がこれはもう良くないって
おそらくもう体に悪いということを考えたと思います
で 注釈書で言ってるのは
この肉食べたら臭いますよと体が
だから体から肉の臭いプンプンしながら森の中にいると
この動物たちに攻撃を受けるんだと
例えば蛇がそこを感じちゃうと
これは敵やと思って攻撃するし
まあ虎の虎が臭いが嗅いじゃうと寄ってくる可能性もあるしね
可愛いんだからね 寄ってきたら
だからまあ そういうことは避けて欲しかった
それから どちらでも凶暴な動物で
馬と馬は牛と同じですからね
食べてもいいんじゃないかなと思ってはいますけど
当時インドでは馬っていうのは王様の財産なんですね
一般人は所有できません
すごい珍しい インドでは馬はそんなにないんです
このイランから戦略されてきた時は馬を持ってきたんだからね
だからそれは王様の特別な財産で
ゾウも同じなんです だから
それ食べちゃうとまずいと
政治的には というような説明なんですけど
まああまりこの品のないものは
仏教はすごい品格を大事にするんだからね
だからまあそれはできるだけ避けます
まあそんな肉を食べたっていう例はないんですけど
たまたまこのお釈迦様にお布施されたとかありますけど
で その時でも まあもう鶏とかね
豚とか まあそんな程度のものや
あるいは魚とかね そんな程度のもので
この変なものはやっぱり食べちゃうと
文化的にこのすごい品格の高いあの出家としてはかっこ悪いぐらいの話なんです
でしょうかね まあとにかくその一つは厳密にしてますけど
はい うん さっき手挙げた方がいい
今回のお話とはあまり関係ないんですけれども
ちょっと聞くだけ読んだことがあるんですけど
ですね 昨日 会社の先輩と酒を飲んでいる時に
その会社の先輩の友人で作家の作家の方がいらっしゃいまして
その方は結構十数年前から
あの なんか宇宙と交信ができるということをおっしゃってたんですけれども
で その作詞を作る時に
そのある状況を自分で整えることで
その作詞の言葉が宇宙から
空から来てくるっていうことをおっしゃられていたんですけど
それそれはその  私がまああの以前本とかで読んだ時に
その仏教の中でも そのまあ修行することで
宇宙と まあ交信点なんですけど
宇宙からその真理ということを教えていただくことができるっていうことをまあ聞いたことがあるんですけれど
宇宙と交信するというのはどういうことなのか
もしご存知なら教えていただけないでしょうか
そんなことは勝手にやらしちゃえばいいんじゃないかって
全く理屈は成り立ってないでしょうにね
宇宙から教えてもらうっていうのは
なんで情けない話ですかね
宇宙の人々を全て知ってますかね
宇宙の生命は 宇宙っていうのは
普遍的に見れば誰でもただの宇宙の生命でしょうね
我々人間で大したことは知らないし
例えば別な惑星に生命がいたっても
そこら辺のことしか知らんでしょうね
理屈はなってないだけで
人から話を聞くと 親の話を聞いたらどうですかね
その野郎が もっと心配しているんだから親がやらないでしょうに
だからまあ あまりそういうことにはね
あ そう 面白いっていうぐらいでいいんじゃないんですかね
妄想の期間内  まあまあ
人のことだからね あまり気にしないでください
あの真理っていうのは
自分が宇宙の一部だから
何も自分に欠けてないんですよ
だからこの心を持ってるでしょうに
宇宙のすべての生命であっても
心と体でしょ 何も欠けてないんですよ
だからそこで真理発見できますよ
誰にも教えてもらうんじゃないんです
そんなに心配するといえば
3人だけですよ もうお釈迦様と両親ですよ
で 両親も頭が悪いんだからね
大したこと教えてくれくれませんし
だからまあ それがあんまり信頼しない方がいいんです
ね まあ個人的な感想で言えば
この宇宙と交信やらなんだらと言うんだけど
ろくなことは言わないんですね
誰も 全く陳文簡文くだらないもので
あるいは全くの証拠で成立することは不可能なことを言ったりするだけ
そんなのが頭がイカれてる人に見えますからね
こちらはお化けがうろうろしているんだぞとかね
それで見せてください
あなた方に見えませんよと言ったら
それで話終わりですからね
だから そういう風に成立不可能なことはダラダラ言うだけの世界ですよ
私もある有名な宗教組織にちょっと頼まれて行ったんですけど
そちらでお祈り終わってからね
すごい人々集めて 女性なんですけど
私にはもうあらゆるジャールの神様はこちらに降臨していらっしゃることはもう見えてますよとかね
なんだこのアホの女と思ったんですけどね
みんな信仰しているかもしれませんだけど
寒いところで また富士山に近いところでね
だからいろいろ組織系をして頼むんだからね
留学生会館の当時いましたし
だからまあいつでもそちらがもうなんとか代表で行って欲しがるんですよ
で 他の人頼むと頼まないんで
やっぱり行ったらすごくまずいしね
あの立場 その呼ぶ人々にとっても
ちょっともう外人と言っても学生だから何するかわからないし
だからすごくおとなしく
物事もわかって理解もして
随分政治的にディプロマティック的に問題解決してくれるんだから
いつでもお願いします
お願いしますばっかりで
私も勉強する暇がほとんどなくなったぐらいで
で 私はいろんなところにと言われるとね
みんなが学生の代表として入って
しっかりと問題を解決して
もう帰る帰ったんですから
自民党にも行ったんですよ
自民党の本部にも まあいろいろなところに行きましたからね
今更学生の口を言っても意味がないんですけど
まあ興味あったんじゃなくて
だからそういう風な宗教組織にも結構行きましたしね
だからそれも一つなんですよ
この国はどうなっているのか
なんでこんなに迷信ばっかしでね
原始的なところに陥るのかと
だって我々の国と比べると
もうもうむちゃくちゃ科学的な世界でしょうに
ものすごいしっかりと
もうもう三歳からも教育を受けたりしてね
それはちょっと見ていられなかったんですね
なのに なんだこの生き方はと
しかし 子供はどうかね
神社の生まれ持って口をつけて
それは違和感はないんですけど
可愛いだけでね もうそれをお母さんの一生懸命つけたっても
それはお母さんの気持ちわかりますからね
そこは美しく映りますけど
それ以外はね どれほど人を怒鳴って追い出したかというとね
もう部屋に来ると 時々あんた方は家の仕事でもしたらどうですかと
無駄な時間使わないで
頭が悪くてもいいんだけど
ペラペラあっちこっち行って言いふらすんじゃないよと
あるキリスト教の聖書なんか持ってきて
あれこれもうメス行きますや
もう全部破壊するんだ
あれやこれとかね そしたら私はあ
そう あんたが勉強してみてくださいと
そしたら私は じゃあ聖書にこの問題どう書いてますか？この問題どう書いてますかと
言うと読んでないんです
あれ どうしましょうかと
だから私はポンカステって開けて
こういうところありますけど
と言ったら そこをそのまま読み上げるだけで
それにむちゃくちゃね
だからダメでしょうと
で 最後に言ったのは この神を信じる人々だけ天国に行って
他の人々はどこへ行くかわからないと
僕はそれでよかったと
あなた方知ってますかとね
あなた方もキリスト教より大きいんだけど
これある組織だからね
あなた方の組織で何人いますかと
世界中 それからあなたの家で親戚みんな信じていますかと
お子さん二人なんです
あなたの家で家族で旦那さん
子供信仰しているんです
他の親戚は信仰していますか？あの友達はみんな信仰していますか？ないでしょうと
だからあんた寂しいんですよと
信者でね 地獄に行ったってもね
私は死んじゃったらね
この親と子供たち 知ってる人々とかね
仲間と一緒にいたんだ
今まで散々お世話になった人々と
まあ一緒に地獄でもしょうがないでしょうと
だから時間を無駄にしないでね
家の仕事でもあったらそれやりなさいと
で 逆にあの我々腰が抜かすと思いますね
紙のなんとか言葉とか持ってきたらね
だから一件 今日は二十件行ったとか
向こうはもうそういうことでしょ
だから朝早く来たんですね
で それでじゃあ今日はあなた方はね
見てみなさいと 朝からもうずーっと四時間ぐらい立ったまんまで
いろんな質問をする 聖書はくったくた読ませる
読んで答え出したところで反論を出す
だってそれにどう答えがあるのかとかね
で 最後にそれ見てもう返しちゃったんです
その日は結構人は助かりましたと思います
人を助けた代わりに私は一人すごい苦労しましたけど
誰もそれは先生もありがたがってくれないんですけど
[笑い]まあそういういろいろね
あってね まああまりにもこの
まあね もうこれは発展する時の同じもの現象かもしれません
アメリカでもすごいバカバカしいでしょうしね
どんなインチキでもすぐもうパクって信じるしね
ヨーロッパの国々でも同じです
発展しちゃうと右も左もわからない状態になっちゃうんですね
だからそこでまあブッダの話でも聞いたらね
もともと文化的にそんな違いも大差じゃないしね
なんかいいことになるんじゃないかなと思ったんです
その人々付き合ってね
いろんな宗教の方々とね
そういうことで あまりこのまあそこはさせてください
その人に宇宙との交信をね
[笑い]邪魔しないでください
じゃあよろしいでしょうか
じゃあ回向の文 回向の文
菩提の三宝に礼拝敬し
拝の後に 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれた功徳を
神々 先祖 祖母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の等しい生き物に回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての等しい生き物が幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨー イヴァンジャンツー サッバローゴー ウィナッサトゥ マテー バワトゥ アンタラーヨー スキーディーガー ヤコー バワー
バワトゥ サッバ マングラッン ラッカンツー サッバデーヴァター サッバブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティ バワントゥティ アビワッダナシーリッス ニッ
チャンワッダ パチャヤーイノー チャッターロー ダンマワッダンティー アユワッノー スカンバラン アユーラーローギャ
サンプッティ サッガ サンプッティ メーワチャ
アトー ニッバーナ サンプッティ イミナーテー サミッジャトゥ
サーリプッタサーリプッタ
では どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました